I become interested in Japan and how did I start to like Japan? Well,
I actually like anime and anime, and I
look like I like Dragon Ball more, but I do
n't like it.
No, but I'm also an anime otaku, so if the
story is good, I'll watch it.Even if I do
n't like an anime, I've
never thought about my favorite characters.But let's just say C.The
reason I became interested in Japan was
Trunks C.  If you say, it's food, then C. Well, after all,
Oiken-chan has the same
hobbies as you.Wait a minute.That's not true.I don't think there are any
Ghibli movies that I really like that are completely different from the previous ones.Well, I don't
think there will be any yet.
There are a lot of Ghibli movies that I haven't seen,
so I guess that's why I
started liking Japan.If it weren't for anime, it would be
JPOP.It's not even J-pop.I
feel like I'm listening to a lot of Ghibli movies at night.Recently, the only
music I've been listening to is Bloodborne.  I have
n't heard of Bloodborne, that's the game. I see, I
got into it from the game. Can you tell me a story
? Who plays Smash in Super Smash Bros. The
last time I played it was in high school, but I
did play it. My favorite Dragon Quest is Eto.
I've never done it before. I love Na too.
Can I ask you to stop making wild predictions? Not all foreigners want to
go to Japan. I'm sorry, but I don't have any
bad intentions.  Not at all, Japanese people
will do that right away,
so it's a stereotype, that's what it is.That's right, that's what
it means.That's bad.It's okay.However, please be
careful in the future.Ah, that's what I heard.The
same source is
interested in Japan.  What made you decide to do it? It's a
martial arts, isn't it? It's a martial arts, after all. It's
from Dragon Ball, after all.